In this course, you will learn to create an
Android app using the jetpack compose UI library.
Along the way, you will learn about graph
algorithms and data structures.
Ryan MK teaches this course.
He is a very experienced developer and instructor.
What's up everybody?
This is Ryan here, and I would like to welcome
you to my tutorial series on the graph Sudoku
application.
This is an application I wrote primarily to
refine my understanding of graph data structures
and algorithms, and the new UI library on
Android jetpack compose.
In this part of the series, I will Overview
The main goals and topics of the series and
discuss a few design decisions which may come
as a surprise to you.
I will try to keep the public version of the
project source code up to date.
And it will be your responsibility to look
at that source code if something becomes deprecated
or stops working.
The format of this series is a code along
style, which implies that the best way to
learn is to write the code with me as I explain
it.
For advanced developers, the full source is
available for direct learning, but you can
watch the videos to clear up any holes in
your knowledge.
I use some fairly advanced features of the
kotlin language and the timeless principles
of software architecture, so you might learn
a thing or two.
For beginners, it is very important that you
follow along with me in code but at your own
pace.
You might not feel like you're making progress
at first, but understand that you will be
practicing the skill of writing code even
if you don't yet understand what you're writing.
I will also secretly be teaching you how to
write code which is easy to write, read, fix,
improve and test.
But instead of asking you to memorize the
timeless principles of software design, you
will learn and use them in practice as we
build this application.
There are four general topics that This tutorial
will demonstrate graph data structures and
algorithms jetpack compose clean UI architectures,
and kotlin language features.
We will explore the topic of directed colored
graphs and my experiments in writing algorithms
to generate solve and unsolved n sized Sudoku
puzzles.
We will build the entire user interface using
jetpack compose, which allows us to create
our UI entirely in kotlin.
As opposed to XML views and styles.
I will show you how to wire up a simple app
using principles commonly expounded in solid
and clean architectures.
However, I teach these topics in my own way,
so do not expect a bunch of jargon or over
engineering.
I will also demonstrate how and when to use
basic and advanced features of this beautiful
programming language.
This part of the video is intended more for
intermediate and advanced developers.
Understanding this design decision is not
required to complete the tutorial.
Throughout this tutorial, you will notice
that apart from compose and proto data store,
I use almost no libraries from Android jetpack
In fact, very few third party libraries in
general, by relying on kotlin and Java standard
libraries and the Android SDK, my code becomes
more resistant to deprecations and changes
in libraries.
This is because the Android SDK, and the standard
libraries tend to change less frequently than
third party libraries, such as those you see
an Android jetpack.
It also means that some things which libraries
like jetpack viewmodel, jetpack, navigation
or help might handle must be hand written
by us.
I actually like that, but you might have a
different value system.
And my goal here is not to discourage you
from learning these tools if you're interested
in them.
With that being said, you might be surprised
at how easy it is to write your own viewmodel
navigation or dependency injection code without
them in a small app like this one.
This application uses Model View whatever
architecture, which is my way of saying that
I don't follow anyone else's style.
Having studied this topic for many years,
I let the project requirements in my understanding
of the principles of good software design
guide my architecture.
In this case, I find that compose is made
for an MVVM based approach, but I added a
presentation logic class for a specific reason.
This reason is called passive view or humble
object.
Instead of having the view or the view model
manage the control flow of each screen, I
pulled that logic into a separate class.
This class is super easy to write and test
because it has no third party dependencies.
And it prevents my view model from becoming
an ugly God object.
You should try it sometime.
I designed this architecture simply by applying
the single most important principle of software
architecture, separation of concerns.
That's it for this part of the series.
Now we begin coding.
The domain package represents two things,
the most general pieces of information, such
as data classes, constants, and enough Which
the program must virtually represent.
Also, the most general things this program
must do, which the program represents using
functions and interfaces.
In essence, it is the foundation of any new
program I rate and I use a repeatable process
to design my domain package or module.
For a clear and simple introduction to that
process.
Check out this video on my channel, how to
design information systems and applications.
That video is a recording of a talk I gave
to some software engineers in Egypt about
that particular topic.
Anyways, most of the code in this package
is simple, but it does include a design pattern,
which I will introduce now.
This package contains several interfaces,
which are used to employ the repository design
pattern.
This pattern is also known as the facade pattern.
And the general goal of the pattern is simpler
than its technical definition.
The technical definition of the facade or
repository pattern is to hide the details
of a subsystem, in this case, data storage
mechanisms behind an abstraction, in this
case, an interface.
Let's look at a practical example.
To make sense out of that definition, our
presentation logic classes will hold references
to these repository interfaces, instead of
the classes which implement the interfaces.
This gives several benefits to our presentation
logic classes.
They can be built independently of each other
without causing a compiler error, they can
be tested with a fake implementation of the
interface without requiring us to change any
code within the presentation logic class.
Also, if we decide to use a different implementation
of the interface, such as switching from file
storage to a room database, we can also do
that without requiring any changes to the
presentation logic class.
These benefits are a result of building software
systems, which are loosely coupled.
And the repository or facade pattern is an
easy way to promote loose coupling.
In fact, interfaces in general tend to promote
loose coupling.
Now don't feel the need to use this pattern
everywhere.
A good general rule is to use them in significant
architectural boundaries.
In this case, I'm using them as a boundary
between the front end and the back end of
this application.
To start things off, right click on the domain
package, go to New kotlin file and create
a file called difficulty.
And that's going to be an enum class.
enum classes in kotlin, and Java and various
other languages are useful for creating a
restricted set of values.
As we'll see later on, you can use sealed
classes in kotlin to create a restricted set
of types.
In any case, the main benefit outside of just
creating that set of restricted values is
that enums can greatly improve the legibility
of your program.
As we'll see in a moment, let's add in our
enum entries.
quite obviously, this enum will represent
the difficulty of a given Sudoku puzzle.
However, we need to add one more thing before
moving on, we will actually be using some
values for each of these entries in the algorithms
to basically dictate the difficulty of the
Sudoku puzzle.
So in order to add a value to an enum in kotlin,
we need to give it a property or some properties.
As you can see, our entries are now read,
so obviously, we need to give them some doubles.
And that's everything we need to do here.
Right click on the main package, go to New
kotlin file for class.
And we're going to create a data class called
settings.
settings is our first data model, as I like
to call it or a plain old kotlin object.
And as we'll see in a moment, it will contain
both the difficulty and the boundary, which
is the size of the Sudoku puzzle.
So a four by four Sudoku puzzle will have
a boundary of four, a nine by nine will have
a boundary of nine.
The data keyword when put ahead of a class
keyword basically adds or generates a couple
of helper methods, such as equals hash code
or copy.
We'll definitely be making use of copy later
on maybe not in this class, but in some of
them and others.
certain point, we will also make use of the
generated hash code function.
Anyways, this is a really simple class, we're
just going to add two properties to it.
And that's it.
Right click on the domain package, go to New
kotlin class or file.
And this time, we're going to create a class
called user statistics.
And that's going to be a data class.
Now, the purpose of this class is to represent
the user's shortest slash best times for solving
any particular difficulty or size of Sudoku
puzzle.
So we're basically just going to add a whole
bunch of properties that are pretty much the
same.
Now, one thing you can do in IntelliJ IDEA,
or Android Studio is you can just click there
and then hit Ctrl D, however many times you
need and that will copy to a new line.
That's basically it for this class.
Now, you might be wondering, why are we using
long here, we're actually storing the time
it takes for the user to complete a particular
game in milliseconds.
So that's why we want the long integer value.
Again, right click on the domain package,
go to New kotlin filer class, and this is
going to be a data class named Sudoku note.
Now, this is where things start to get a little
more complicated and interesting with our
data models.
So what I'm doing here is I'm representing
an individual node in a graph data structure,
we're going to talk a lot more about graph
data structures later on when we get to the
part of the tutorial dedicated to it.
But just to give you an idea, so we are actually
going to be building a directed colored graph.
And an important thing here to note is that
in this particular case, this term color really
just refers to a number, it's just a value
we associate in some kind of node.
And again, to give you a preview ahead, when
I say graph data structure, a better name
for it would be a network data structure,
because that's essentially what it is.
It's a collection of nodes, and edges, which
are essentially like lines between the nodes
relationships between the nodes.
Anyways, this particular node structure in
our data structure is going to have a color
or a value, which is just an integer from
one through nine or one to four, also, including
00 represents like an empty Sudoku tile, but
that's more concern of the front end.
These notes will also include an X and Y coordinate,
so the top left will be x zero y zero, the
bottom right will be x eight, y eight, and
we're going to be using Zero Based indexing.
So instead of starting from x one to x nine,
we just basically subtract that by one.
So that's it for that preamble, let's get
started writing the code.
So we'll start with the x and y values.
Next, we will add the color which will be
a variable because it can change throughout
the course of execution.
Then we will add a Boolean called read only
and I'll explain what that is after we write
it.
Now, the purpose of the read only Boolean
here is quite simple.
When we essentially generate and then unsolved
a Sudoku puzzle, which is another way of saying
we create a new Sudoku puzzle then remove
a certain number of clues to make the game
actually playable and fun.
Some of those numbers on the Sudoku board
or in the Sudoku graph data structure will
be read only those are like the given clues
that the user is not supposed to be able to
change themselves.
As we'll see later on.
This will also affect the user interface because
we will draw the read only Sudoku nodes or
tiles differently than the ones which the
user can edit.
Now, we're not quite done yet, we need to
override the hash code function which was
provided by the data class keyword as I discussed
earlier, and then we also need to add a function
to get a hash code.
Okay, so hash code will have a default implementation,
which is based on the values provided up here
in the different properties, we're actually
just going to do something different.
So we're going to type get hash, like that.
And this is actually a function that we are
going to create also, we'll add in two parameters
here for x and y.
Okay, we're now going to add the get hash
function, and it's going to be top level,
which means it sits outside the brackets of
our Sudoku node class.
Okay, let's just implement this function,
and then I'll explain what we're doing here.
Okay, so let me start by explaining what exactly
a hash code or hash value is.
So it's essentially some kind of generated
key or unique identifier based on some kind
of algorithm.
In this case, I have a very simple algorithm,
all I do is multiply the x value by 100.
And I leave the y value alone.
And I basically just combine those two values
together into an integer.
Now, the reason why I multiply x by 100, is
if I didn't do that in a nine by nine Sudoku
puzzle, there would be certain edge cases
where the even though the X and Y value are
technically different, the resulting hash
code would not be unique for several different
nodes.
Simply put, I'm multiplying by 100 to make
the hash codes unique for every individual
tile in the Sudoku puzzle.
As for why we're using hash code, in general,
I'll try and keep it fairly straightforward.
Basically, we're going to be storing each
node in the graph in a linked hash map.
So the hash values will represent the key
for that hash map.
A hash map has key value pairs, in case you're
not aware it, we'll be seeing that in a moment.
But this turns out to be really useful because
our user interface as well will be representing
things in that kind of X and Y coordinate
style.
So just take my word for it.
Hash codes are pretty handy in situations
where you have a large number of elements,
and you don't necessarily want to have to
maintain a reference for every individual
element.
Instead, we can just retrieve a reference
by getting a hash code.
Oh, and before we go, we need to add one more
thing here, we're going to make this thing
implement serializable.
Now essentially, what this does is it allows
us to read and write our Sudoku nodes and
also the whole puzzle to a file.
Since we're only going to be storing one puzzle
at a time, I didn't really want to use something
like a database, it kind of just made more
sense to use the file system, and serializable
and makes it easier to do that essentially.
Okay, we have one final data model to create
in this particular package again, right click
New kotlin file our class, this one's going
to be called Sudoku puzzle.
And again, it's going to be a data class.
A good way to think of data models, as I like
to call them is that they are virtual representations
of a real world object, in this case, a Sudoku
puzzle.
The way that I initially designed this class
is by asking critical questions about what
constitutes a Sudoku puzzle.
Things like the boundaries, so are there four
tiles per row or column or are there nine
tiles for example, we have the difficulty.
And most importantly, we have the graph data
structure itself.
There's also the elapsed time which the user
has taken to solve a particular puzzle.
So let's go ahead and add those properties
in and then I'll explain some of them the
ones that need to be explained afterwards.
Also, before I forget, let's add in the serializable
implementation here.
Okay, so you're probably wondering what build
new Sudoku is.
So what we'll be doing is we're actually going
to be calling a large series of top level
functions, which will form all of our different
algorithms, which are necessary to build and
generate a new Sudoku puzzle, based on a given
size, which is what boundary represents and
a given difficulty.
Also, if you're wondering about what's going
on with the linked hash map, which is full
of linked lists, that's kind of a way of representing
an adjacency list.
Again, I'm going to go into those details
on graph data structures and different ways
you can represent them, or at least how I
represent them in this particular application
later when we get to that particular package
and topic.
But for the time being understand this represents
our virtual Sudoku puzzle, the last thing
we're going to do is just add in a small little
method, which just makes it a little more
obvious and legible how to get ahold of the
graph itself, at least in my opinion.
And we're going to use single expression syntax.
So I'm just going to type equals graph.
Let's create a new interface called I game
repository.
I like to use this naming convention of putting
a capital I in front of the interfaces.
And then as we'll see later on, in the persistence
package, I will add a suffix of I MPL, which
stands for implementation to naturally the
classes which implement this interface.
When designing a small to medium scale application,
one thing you can do is you can actually conceptually
think of the functions in your repository
interfaces.
As use cases themselves, the things we're
going to be writing here are going to be called
like save game update game update node, which
is very similar if you're doing like a user
stories in the use cases type application
design.
So I just wanted to throw that in there.
In a more complicated application, where I
needed to do more coordination of multiple
different data sources and repositories, I
probably would have like an interactor, or
a use case, as it's commonly talked about,
between Martin Fowler or Robert Martin, Uncle
Bob.
But in this particular case, in simpler applications,
generally speaking, the use case as a class
itself, is typically an unnecessary extra
layer of abstraction.
So with here, we're just going with our presenter,
or view model or whatever, talking directly
to a repository.
And that is a sufficient amount of abstraction
for an application of this size.
Now, how an interface works is that it's very
similar to a class except as we'll see, in
a moment, we're not actually allowed to implement
or give a body to the functions that we'll
be writing, we just write what are commonly
called either abstract functions or functions
stubs.
Now there's two important points here.
Firstly, the suspend keyword is applied there,
because these functions will actually be called
from co routine scopes, which exists in the
logic class or the presenter that will be
referencing this particular interface.
So that's all we need to do to establish concurrency
for now.
Now, in case you're not familiar, what I'm
using here is what's known as a function type.
And so what we'll do is we will be actually
passing in a reference to two functions which
exist in the logic class the presentation
logic will pass those functions in.
And then in the repository implementations
the things which implement this particular
interface, that is how they will call back
with some kind of result, either a successful
result or a failure.
Now you might be wondering, why do we have
unit and then it returns unit which is what
that arrow means, in this particular case?
This is something we kind of have to do in
order for the kotlin compiler to understand
exactly what we're telling it to do.
So this would be kind of equivalent to passing
in void or like basically nothing into this
particular function, and then returning nothing
from that particular function.
But what it will do is it will signal something
like an oncomplete if you have any experience
with RX Java, where basically we just want
to resume the application successfully when
this function is called.
But this particular function does not actually
need to return anything.
Later on, we'll see some examples of when
we actually need to return a value through
our on success function type.
Again, you might be wondering what is the
difference between saving a game and updating
a game?
Well, essentially, in the update game function,
we're going to be wholesale writing an entire
Sudoku puzzle, which includes an elapsed time,
although there are some situations where all
we really need to do is simply update the
elapsed time of the game, such as when the
user navigates away from the application.
So what I'm doing here is I'm creating sort
of specialized functions depending on what
we want to achieve from the user's point of
view.
Now I'm going to demonstrate when we actually
want to return a value from these particular
function types.
Okay, so for onsuccess, what we're effectively
saying here is that this particular function
must be called with some kind of Boolean value,
obviously, either true or false when it's
called in the implementation of this particular
suspending function.
Now, basically, what we're doing here is when
the user updates a single node or tile in
a Sudoku puzzle, there's a possibility that
that might be the final tile in the puzzle.
And in that particular case, assuming the
puzzle is correct, and the user has inputted,
the final tile, that would signal that the
gain is complete.
So it might be a little bit confusing here.
But onsuccess does not necessarily mean that
the game itself has been completed.
So that's why I'm differentiating there.
Okay, now, in this particular case, what we're
doing is when the user returns to an active
game, we obviously want to get a current game.
And there is actually an edge case where the
user completes the game, navigates away from
the application, and then restarts the application.
And so that's why we're still passing in that
is complete flag.
Here we're going to return obviously, a settings
object.
Let's create another interface.
And it's going to be called I gain, data storage.
And that's obviously an interface.
Now, before we write the interface itself,
we're going to do something a little bit different.
We are going to create a result wrapper or
Well, let's just say it's inspired by an either
mon ad from functional programmers, but no
one really cares what functional programmers
think or talk about anyways.
Seal classes are truly one of my favorite
simple features of the kotlin programming
language.
It allows us to create In a restricted set
of types, and those types can contain particular
values, and visca.
What this will do And as we'll see in a moment
is it allows us to return an object from a
particular function have I gained data storage,
and this particular object is capable of representing
multiple different states.
So like I showed you before in AI game repository,
here, we're representing an error state and
a success state as two separate function references.
In this example, we're going to be representing
both of those states through a single object.
Now, one final point, before we move on, if
you have, for example, some kind of situation
where you want to represent just a success
case, so equivalent to just returning unit
in onsuccess, what you can do is you can actually
just use an object so you could say like object
on complete, etc.
But we don't actually do the that in this
application.
So you don't need to add that in.
Now, let's finish off
the interface.
Create another interface called I settings
storage.
Now, we're also going to use result wrappers
here.
So I'm actually going to just copy and paste
this over.
And we're just going to rename a few things.
Okay, and now we can write the interface.
One more interface to go for this package.
This one is going to be called pi statistics
if I can spell it repository, and obviously,
it's going to be an interface.
Now one final point, again, is record is going
to actually affect something in the user interface
based on whether or not a statistic that gets
updated is a record ie the shortest possible
time of completion for a particular boundary
or size of Sudoku puzzle, and a particular
difficulty.
The common package contains code which is
reused in a variety of different classes and
functions.
In this part of the tutorial, we will learn
about many different kotlin language features,
which are designed for sharing code in an
intelligent and efficient way.
Topics covered include extension functions
and problem These abstract classes, the open
closed principle, object, Singleton, and co
routine dispatchers.
Before we write the code, let's talk about
the open closed principle.
The OCP is a relatively confusing concept,
but I will try to explain it in the clearest
way i can to give you my own verbal definition,
which we'll break down later.
Any commonly reused software entity, which
is expected to change should have a fixed
public interface, and a way to change its
implementation.
In order for that particular definition to
make sense, there's a couple things that I
need to unpack.
Firstly, when I say software entity, I'm generally
speaking about a class or a function, but
it could be a few other things.
So let's examine what I mean by public interface
and why I argue that it should be fixed if
it's commonly reused.
By public interface, I am not speaking of
a Java or kotlin interface specifically, instead,
I mean any publicly visible aspect of a class
or a function.
Since this is an Android tutorial, let us
take the example of the activity class.
An activity fits my requirement of being commonly
reused and expected to change over time.
So it is a perfect case to think about the
OCP.
Every subclass of activity must include the
onCreate function, which is a part of the
public interface, which it makes available
to classes which reference it.
The reason why we want this public interface
not to change is very simple.
Suppose that the Android platform developers
suddenly decided to deprecate and remove saved
instance, state bundles from all lifecycle
functions.
Because this public interface is used by pretty
much every Android program around this platform
update would break everyone's code.
What I mean specifically is that all activity
subclasses in all code bases, which have not
removed this parameter would not be able to
compile.
So this is why I'm talking specifically about
commonly reused software entities like activity,
and why it is important that their public
interfaces change as little as possible.
Since we've established why fixed public interfaces
are really important.
The next question is simple.
How do we then provide a mechanism or way
for the implementation of the public interface
to change?
Well, it turns out the kotlin gives you many
options to solve this problem.
Rather than explain them all, verbally, I
will teach you how to use them in code.
As we build this application, right click
on the common package, and go to new Colin
filer class.
And this is actually going to be an abstract
class which they don't give an option for
here.
So what we're going to do is type in base
logic, we will add in the abstract keyword.
Unfortunately, I don't have the time to explain
the difference between an abstract class and
interface in plain old inheritance.
In this particular course, this is something
I go into and explained very clearly in my
other video courses.
But what I will do is explain why we're using
an abstract class here instead of an interface.
The reason why we would want to use an abstract
class is for situations when we want to share
behavior.
So for example, we'll be writing a function
stub or abstract function, which I want to
be shared across any class, which inherits
from base logic.
And I also want to share a variable, but this
particular variable will have to be protected
as opposed to public.
And if we were to try and do this using an
interface, then necessarily that particular
value would be public, we're also going to
use a generic type.
So I'll show you how to do that.
So the syntax for a generic type is to just
use angle brackets.
And then you could take quite literally whatever
you wanted between those angle brackets.
But my suggestion to you is to not use something
which is already used, hence why I'm using
this all capitals event.
Now, if it doesn't make sense what we're doing
here, it will make more sense when we write
the classes which inherit from base logic.
Let's go ahead and finish this off.
To briefly explain the intent of this abstract
class.
Basically, I'm saying that I want a set of
classes, the ones which will inherit from
base logic, all of which will have this function
on event.
In other words, these classes will handle
events from the user interface.
And then as we'll see, we're going to use
this job object which comes from the coroutines
API as a way to Cancel child co routines.
And also to make each of these logic classes
as its own co routine scope.
I'll explain that when we get to that particular
part of the tutorial, right click on the common
package and create a new kotlin file, which
is just going to be a plain old file, and
it's going to be called extensions.
gotlands extension functions and extension
properties are among my favorite features
of the language as a whole.
Without getting too technical here, extensions
allow you to employ the open closed principle,
which states that software entities should
be open for extension, but closed for modification.
If that doesn't make sense, don't worry about
it is kind of a confusing definition.
But it allows us to add new functionality
to existing source code without having to
modify the original source code.
Now, this particular file extensions.kt is
kind of like a replacement for static utilities
that we might have used in Java or something
like that.
It's really just a place where you stick utility
code which is used across the application.
Let's write our first extension function to
see how this works.
The purpose of this particular extension function,
obviously it will be used within activities
is really just syntactic sugar, its way to
make it so that I don't have to type out toast
dot make text and supply this message toast
dot length long and dot show.
Instead, in the activity where we'll be using
activities, I should say where we'll be using
this particular extension function, we can
just type make toast, give it whatever string
we want to display, and it's handled like
that.
By making it an extension function of the
activity class, I can use it seamlessly in
any activity.
Let's write another much uglier utility extension
function.
The purpose of this ugly little function here
is to take the elapsed time of the given puzzle
which the user is currently working on, and
to attempt to convert it into a value based
on minutes and seconds or a string to display
based on minutes and seconds.
Now, if it takes the user longer than an hour,
then we end up just displaying like a generic
more than 5959.
Now if you think this code is ugly, in kotlin,
I challenge you to write it in Java.
Now for beginners, this might not make sense
intuitively, but it's important to understand
what this is referring to.
This is actually referring to the long object,
which we will be calling dot two time on.
That might make a little bit more sense when
we actually get to using this particular extension
function.
There's only one more extension, we need to
add, and it's actually going to be an extension
property this time.
So what I'm doing here is I'm hitting alt,
enter on this particular red thing, and then
I'm going to hit Add remaining branches.
going to hit alt enter, again, to import our,
these are obviously string resources.
That's one thing, we're not going to be writing
by hand.
So hopefully, what you've done is you've gone
and grabbed the source code for the starting
point, which includes things like string resources,
right click on the common package again, and
we're going to create a new kotlin interface,
which is going to be called dispatcher provider.
This interface is very small, what we'll do
is we'll write the code and then I'll briefly
explain what it does.
Now, unfortunately, I can't briefly explain
what a co routine context is.
But I can't explain the purpose of this particular
class and how we're going to be using these
co routine contexts.
So in most situations, most of the work that
we're going to be doing within co routines
land is going to take place on the main thread
or the UI thread.
Now, with that being said, there are a few
operations like writing to a file, which we
don't actually want to occur on the main thread.
And that would be a situation where we're
going to provide the IO context.
Now, the actual purpose of this particular
interface is really key here.
What we're going to be doing is that if we
wanted to hypothetically test any class, which
needs to use these co routine contexts, in
a JVM environment, so not an actual running
application, then what we could do is we could
return a particular kind of CO routine context,
which allows us to test in that particular
environment.
I know that's a lot of technical detail, but
I can't really make it a whole lot simpler
than that.
However, by using this interface here, when
we want to use our co routines in the production
environment, we can provide the real UI main
thread context for the front end, and then
we can provide a real dispatcher for the IO
thread.
To make that even simpler, we're really just
making the code easier to test.
Right click on the common package, go to New
kotlin file or class, this time, it's going
to be an object.
And hopefully I can spell this right production
dispatcher provider.
Again, what we'll do is we'll write the code
here and then I'll explain how it works afterwards.
I'm going to hit alt Enter again.
And this is where we will return the actual
dispatchers that we'll be using in production
as per the name of this particular object.
Now there's a number of reasons why I'm using
the object keyword here.
So basically objects in kotlin are in this
particular case Singleton's.
So that basically means that we will only
ever have one of these production dispatcher,
a provider software thingies floating around
in memory space at one particular time.
They're also thread safe, which is important
because although co routine is not necessarily
a thread, our dispatchers dot main and dispatchers.io
has something to do with threading.
And the other thing that an object can do
is it can actually inherit from an interface.
Now we're not actually going to be writing
any unit tests in this particular application,
which require the dispatchers but just to
show you What you would do if you wanted to
unit test some class which needs to use these
co routine context, what you can do is you
can just instead return dispatchers dot unconfined,
and then you would return that for both the
IO context and the UI context.
And then that is what you would use in like
a JVM j unit test environment.
The persistence package contains classes and
functions, which have the role of persisting
or storing data beyond the lifecycle of an
Android process.
If you don't know what a process is, it simply
means a program which is running on a device.
Practically speaking, we will store the progress
which the user has made in the current Sudoku
game, as well as the settings for that game,
and the user's personal records or statistics,
as I call them.
Here's a quick look at the architecture of
the persistence package.
The game repository in this situation functions
as a back end decision maker for the two data
sources, which coordinates the data sources
themselves.
Just try to carry out CRUD operations, create,
read, update, delete, and either report with
a success or a failure if an exception is
thrown.
The general principle here is to keep things
together, which makes sense to be kept together
to separate what doesn't need to be kept together,
and to also use an abstraction or an interface.
In any place where the implementation might
change, I might decide to stop using the local
file storage or proto data store.
So hiding these details from the repository
is not over engineering, but rather a calculated
decision.
Speaking of data sources or storage mechanisms,
we will use two different mechanisms for storing
our data.
Firstly, we will store the user's preferred
Game Settings and their personal statistics
in protro data store data store provides a
lightweight and efficient way to store this
kind of data using protocol buffers.
Protocol Buffers is a serialization language
similar to JSON.
However, I find it easier to read than JSON.
And fortunately, the library we will use also
comes with its own protobuf compiler that
will generate some of the boilerplate code
which we would otherwise need to write ourselves.
We also use the device's file storage to store
the progress of the user in the currently
active game.
Every Android app is given some memory space
to store files, which is what we will use.
This is done by making all of the domain models
implement serializable.
And using Java as input and output streams
to read and write objects from kotlin language.
So in case you aren't following along with
the tutorial, and you haven't downloaded the
starting point repository, what you're going
to want to do is you're going to want to add
a directory called pro tau in the main source
set, the starting point repository should
already have that directory.
So just go ahead and right click on it, and
go to new file.
And this file is going to be called gain underscore
settings, dot proto, and make sure it's all
lowercase.
Go ahead and type this in the top of the file.
So protocol buffers are essentially like a
serialization language.
It's very similar to JSON.
If you want to look more into it, you can
about what the benefits and the pros and cons
of using something like JSON.
But personally, this being the only project
that I've used Protocol Buffers in so far,
I'm quite happy with it.
Okay, so let's just add two more lines.
And I'll explain some more from there.
Okay, so we'll talk a little bit more about
this in a moment.
But basically, what's going to happen here
is, we're going to define this protocol buffer
message, as it's called, which is kind of
like a data type for lack of a better term.
And what we can do is, so this file will be
consumed by something called the protocol
buffer compiler.
And in this case, what we're basically telling
it is that we're going to be generating Java
files.
Now in the generated class files.
The protocol buffer compiler is going to basically
add whatever we put in the Java package as
the package for the generated Java class file.
It's just useful to not mix up your namespaces
and stuff like that.
And as for the second option, here, Java,
multiple files.
If you don't have that turned on, then what
can happen is that basically, the generated
Java files will all be in one single file.
We don't really want that, although I'm not
sure if it's absolutely integral to getting
this application to work.
Like I say, we're going to go through this
pretty practically and I'm not an expert in
protocol buffers.
Okay, now, we're going to do Line a message
which is kind of like one of the main data
types for lack of a better term in this particular
language.
Okay, so let's talk about what we just did
here.
So we've defined a message, which in Protocol
Buffers is kind of like a data type or a collection
of fields.
And we've done two things.
So within the game settings message, we have
a 32 bit integers, like a kind of a smaller
integer to represent the boundary of a Sudoku
puzzle.
So when I say boundary, I mean like a four
by four Sudoku puzzle will have a boundary
of four, a nine by nine Sudoku puzzle will
have a boundary of nine, obviously.
And the other thing we did here is we defined
an enum in protocol buffers.
Now when you're creating these enums, you'll
need like a default value unknown.
And then you've got the other values that
the enum can potentially be.
Also notice how in boundary and difficulty
the fields above the enum I'm giving it default
values, naturally, those will be like the
values that the protocol buffer gets pre loaded
with, like the first time you access it.
Now, the important thing to understand here
is that assuming you've added the support
for Protocol Buffers into your build Gradle
configuration, the proto buffer compiler is
going to actually generate some Java files
or classes out of this particular message.
Okay, so what I'm doing here is I've opened
up the completed project, and I'm just having
a look at the file which was generated by
the protocol buffer compiler.
And all I really want you to notice here is
that when you're using proto data store, what's
going to happen is it's actually going to
generate a Java class for you.
Obviously, you can see we have our gain settings
in camel case, which is what we defined as
our message.
And then we also have that enum defined below.
So what does this actually do for us, basically,
this is going to allow us to serialize or
basically translate from Java into the protocol
buffer language and vice versa.
And it also means that we don't actually have
to create our own plain old Java object in
order to do that.
The library is going to generate that for
us.
But we can still use it in our code, which
we'll do in a moment, we're going to add one
more proto file.
So go ahead and open up the protobuf directory,
right click again, go to file.
And this one's going to be called user statistics
dot Proto.
Alright, so I've just copied and pasted the
first three lines from the other protocol
because we'll be reusing them.
And we are going to create another message
here.
Now when I say statistics, this is kind of
like my way of talking about the user's personal
records.
So what are the shortest times to completion
that a user has made in solving a particular
size and difficulty in a particular Sudoku
puzzle?
It's pretty straightforward.
So let's just write it out.
And there you have it.
Now, you might be wondering why I'm using
64 bit integers here.
So these actual values are going to be stored
in milliseconds, which is why I do want the
64 bit integer storage there instead of the
32 bit integer.
I'm not actually 100% sure if that's necessary,
but I did that just to be safe, and realistically,
it's not really going to eat up that much
extra memory.
Okay, so that's it for our protocol buffer
files.
Now, we're going to have to create some protocol
buffer data stores, which is how we're actually
going to create and access our protocol buffers.
Go ahead and right click on the persistence
package, go to New kotlin file or class and
this is just going to be a file called data
stores.
Okay, so before proceeding, you're going to
want to go to build and make project.
Now the build will probably fail, but all
we really wanted to do is to generate the
appropriate Java class out of the protocol
buffer.
But if for some reason that doesn't work for
you, just follow along, and eventually it
will work.
Okay, so for each protocol buffer based data
source, we're going to need to provide a way
to get ahold of it or create it from context,
then the other thing we'll need is a serializer.
Go ahead and import everything.
And there's two things we need to add into
the delegate here.
Okay, so don't worry that it's showing up
red will actually write this serializer.
Next, so I just wanted to explain what's going
on here.
So we're creating a data store object, and
it takes the protocol buffer generated Java
class, which is called Game Settings.
And essentially, what this does is it creates
a reference which which we can use to either
store or retrieve our protocol buffer.
Now, you might be wondering what game underscore
setting.pb is, and why it has a different
file extension than our proto files, to the
best of my understanding game underscore settings.
PB is something that's generated after the
fact by the compiler, whereas the profile
is something we write for the compiler to
consume.
But in case I'm wrong on that, then feel free
to flame me on Twitter.
The other thing we'll need is a serializer,
which takes care of serialization quite obviously.
After that, you can just click here, hit alt
insert, override methods, and we only need
the methods from the serializer interface.
So again, let's read the code and then I'll
explain what I need to explain after the fact.
Okay, so I'm going to keep the details here
pretty light.
So obviously, when we create our data store,
it's given the game setting serializer here.
And what the serializer does is it helps us
to read and write from input streams.
So in other words, we're going to be obviously
reading from a protocol buffer file, and then
that's going to be serialized, or rather D
serialized into Java, and vice versa.
So basically, what the Android team has done
for us here is they've made it a lot easier
to handle things like error handling and dealing
with input streams.
Because if you've ever worked with input streams
in Java, then you can tell there's, you know,
you're probably familiar with a lot of boilerplate
code to do with that.
So basically, we do a little bit of boilerplate
work here.
And it translates to a very simple API, when
we actually want to read and write with this
particular tool in the back end, which we'll
be doing in a moment.
Okay, now, obviously, we need to write another
data store and also serializer for the other
data type.
So this is going to be one of those rare scenarios
where I do actually just copy and paste because
there's absolutely nothing new, we're just
going to change a couple of the words.
So this would be one of the points where I
encourage you to have the complete source
code open on the side and then that way, you
can do a little bit of copy paste action,
like I'm going to do now.
And that is our data stores file complete.
Now obviously, if you had a whole bunch of
these, you'd probably want to use separate
files, but since I only have Have the two
I just decided to stick them in the same file,
right click on the persistence package and
go to New kotlin class.
This one's going to be called local game storage
ample.
So firstly, we're going to make a constant
which will represent the name of the text
file that we will be reading and writing the
game data to.
Next, we'll create the constructor.
So you might be wondering where file storage
directory comes from.
When we create the build logic of this application,
which is kind of like my inversion of control
dependency injection type stuff, what's going
to happen is we're going to call this one
function to the Android system, which will
return us the specific directory from the
system where we can read and write things
like files.
Let's go ahead and implement the interface.
Now, I'm going to try to get through this
relatively quickly.
But one thing I want to explain is that you'll
notice I'm making fairly extensive usage of
helper functions.
The reason for that is just to avoid writing
redundant code.
Also, as with the other implementations, we're
going to be using the width context co routine
builder to do this kind of IO work off of
the main thread.
So what we'll do is we'll call a helper function
called update game data, and we'll pass it
in the game data.
And if that operation happens to be successful,
then we'll actually just return the same game
object that was passed in because it should
be consistent.
Okay, now we can create the helper.
So here, we're going to throw the exception
so that it'll actually get picked up by the
catch block in the functions that we'll be
calling this helper.
Now, we're going to be using input and output
streams, which are part of the Java standard
library in order to rate our data to and from
the file.
If you're wondering kind of what this word
stream means, ultimately, what we're actually
doing kind of at the low level, is we're going
to take our game or Sudoku puzzle object,
and we're going to serialize it into basically
a stream or a very long sequence of textual
characters.
And that's what we'll actually be reading
and writing from the file.
Okay, so two points, you always want to close
your streams.
Also, you might be wondering, how is it that
we can say dot write object and pass in our
Sudoku puzzle, but let's just check the parameters
here.
So I'm going to hit Ctrl p within the parameter
brackets, and as you can see, it accepts any
type.
Now the important thing is that if our different
classes like Sudoku puzzle and Sudoku node
did not extend serializable than we wouldn't
be able to do this without errors.
So for update node, it's a little bit different,
we're just updating one individual node.
So how this is going to work is we're going
to get the old data and then we're just going
to update that individual node.
And then we will rewrite the result back to
storage.
So get game will be another helper, we write,
and what I'm going to do is I'm actually going
to write that one right away.
Otherwise, the autocomplete and error handling
stuff will be all over the place.
Okay, that's what we need to do there.
Now, just a quick reminder here, when we say
color, and really, whenever anyone talks about
a color in a graph data structure, they're
really just talking about a number.
So in this case, the number represents the
actual value placed in a particular Sudoku
square.
So it'll be like something from one through
nine, or one through four, depending on the
boundary of the Sudoku
will also update the elapsed time.
After it's updated, we will write that result
to storage hopefully.
And just to keep the front end synchronized
with everything else, then we will return
that same game object.
Now it has just come to my attention that
I have forgotten to add a particular integer
called color to this particular function when
I wrote it, so let's just go ahead and fix
that now.
There we go.
And I managed to save the easiest for last.
And that's it for this file.
Right click on the persistence package, go
to New kotlin class, this one's going to be
called game repository info.
So in case you jumped ahead, and you aren't
actually familiar with the repository pattern,
I actually already explained that in part
two of this series where I built the domain
package.
In any case, let me just reiterate, reiterate
what the purpose of this particular classes,
it's basically like a bridge and decision
maker for the backend.
Now sometimes you'll have multiple different
repositories or datasets.
In the back end, and it might be a good idea
to keep them separate.
The reason why I didn't in this particular
case is because the game storage and the settings
storage are actually inextricably linked.
They are by nature closely related.
So based on that, and the fact that this isn't
actually a very large application, I chose
to put them together within this repository.
And then how it will work is that the repository
will coordinate these two different data sources.
Let's start with the constructor and the repository
interface.
Okay, so as you can see, we have our work
cut out for us.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to try
to write the code relatively quickly.
And after it's written, I'll explain what
it does.
So there shouldn't be anything new in this
particular function, except for the fact that
we're making an assignment statement within
a control statement, Val current game result
equals etc.
We're allowed to do that because kotlin is
a beautiful and idiomatic language.
This one's actually pretty simple.
You know, for the life of me, I don't understand
why it keeps putting on air on top.
I'll explain this function in a moment.
So puzzle is complete is actually a function
which exists in the computation logic package,
which we'll be writing later on, of course,
and all it does is exactly what it says.
But it will return either a true or a false
based on whether the puzzle is complete or
not.
Hence is complete.
Okay, so what I've done here is I've copied
and pasted in the plain language use case
which describes this particular function.
Now, as you can see, it's pretty complicated
to give a basic explanation of what's going
on.
And why did this when we request the current
game, ie when the application starts up, there's
a number of different things that could happen.
So for starters, the user could have a currently
active game and they just want to retrieve
it.
It could be the first run of the application,
so no game currently exists in storage.
And then there are different situations where
errors could occur along the way.
This is something that happens when you're
coordinating multiple different data sources.
Now I have my own system of tracking these
different event streams, I use basically letters
and numbers to denote steps and different
potential event streams.
But whatever you do, my suggestion to you
is to write this down in plain language first
and then go ahead writing the code.
That's what I did this comment above you see
here, I wrote that before I wrote the code.
Anyways, let's get started.
Okay, so for our first Event Stream, we attempt
to retrieve the current game, and that returned
successfully.
And then we also want to know whether the
current game is complete or not.
We can just get rid of oncomplete.
And here we go again.
So this is obviously the case where the user
has first loaded the application and we want
to create a brand new game.
And Looks like I'll have to do this manually
this time.
The autocomplete is not helping me here.
But in fairness, we haven't written that function
yet.
Okay, I'm just gonna double check that I wrote
that correctly.
Now, before I want to move on, I want to explain
one thing about my perspective on software
architecture.
While sometimes in a simpler application,
we can do something like have the presenter
coordinate different repositories or back
end data sources.
In this particular case, there was enough
complicated back end logic that I wanted to
have also a decision maker class, which happened
to be this game repository imple on the back
end, and part of the purpose of this class
is to take care of the logic of coordinating
these different back end data sources, so
that I can keep the presentation logic class
doing what it's supposed to do, managing presentation
logic, and then I have this class dealing
with this messy kind of almost business logic
type stuff here.
Anyways, we're not done yet.
Okay, so it just occurred to me that I have
missed a function in the interface of a game
repository.
So let's just go ahead and add that in.
So what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to copy update game, paste it down below.
And what we're going to call this is create
new game.
And it's going to take in a settings object
and that's it.
So that's actually a helper function that
I created mostly for legibility, let's just
go ahead and add that in right now.
Just another quick note here, you'll notice
that I like incredibly long and descriptive
names of everything that's going on.
This is largely because I don't have a great
memory for fine details.
So by making these things super long and descriptive,
I don't actually have to remember them, I
can just read my code and pretty much understand
what it does.
Even in these complicated situations where
we have all these different event streams
and interactions occurring, okay, only two
more short functions to go.
And that's it for our back end.
In the top level of the UI package, we have
four small files, which we will use to create
and apply styles, colors, fonts, and so on.
One of those files is the global theme for
our application.
And I will show you how to create both a light
and dark theme for the app in only a few extra
lines of code.
Stay tuned for the end of this section, as
I will do a live demo of the different themes.
Right click on the UI package and create a
new kotlin file, which is going to be called
color dot Katie.
This file will essentially be a replacement
for colors dot XML, if you're used to working
with the old resources system, which was based
in XML, let's create a color object.
Make sure you import the Compose color class.
Okay, so before we proceed, the most important
thing to understand here is how to read these
particular values.
So the first two characters here 0x.
This basically tells the compiler, which is
the program that will be reading this code
that this is in fact a hexadecimal number.
The second two digits here indicates the alpha
value as a percentage.
Alpha is another way of saying transparency
or how opaque something is.
The remaining three pairs are the red, blue,
and green or RGB values, again in a hexadecimal
percentage, and that's pretty much all there
is to know about these different color values.
I've copied and pasted over the rest of the
values because there's absolutely no point
in either was typing all this out.
But also keep in mind that they have some
predefined values such as flack, for example,
which you can also make use of right click
on the UI package, and we're going to create
another new kotlin file.
And this one's going to be called shape.
So in the old view system, when you wanted
to do something like creating a background
with rounded corners, or a button or widget
or something like that, you had to create
usually something inside of the drawable folder,
which was XML based.
Again, since this is compose, we can just
go ahead and do that in kotlin instead.
And we'll just use some default parameters.
Now, this might be your first time seeing
the.dp extension, let's just take a quick
look at the source code.
So as you can see, you can basically just
append it to an integer double and various
kinds of numbers.
The important thing to understand here is
that this basically tells the Compose framework
that we want to use density independent pixels.
If you want a more profound explanation of
what exactly those are, I strongly suggest
you look into it because it's a little bit
complicated.
Suffice it to say that the idea here is to
allow the framework to create values for heights
and widths and things like that would work
across a variety of different screen sizes
and form factors.
Right click on the UI package, and we're going
to create another kotlin file, this one is
going to be called type.
Now in case you're wondering, when we say
type, we're not really talking about a type
system, or anything to do with type theory,
it has to do with type Pog, Rafi or text and
how this text is styled or presented.
So again, this is very much the kind of thing
that we used to do and styles dot XML, we're
basically going to create a bunch of different
text styles, which will use throughout the
application.
And then we'll kind of see how to wrap those
up in a typography object.
And then we'll see how to add that typography
object to our sort of global compose theme.
First, let's create a text style.
Sometimes we have a situation where we want
to keep a bunch of default values, but we
might want one or two values, which are actually
passed in as a parameter to create the text
style object.
So I'll show you another way to create these
text styles using function.
Just gonna do some quick copy paste here.
And then we can override the color.
So again, what I'm going to do for the rest
of these textiles now that we've seen everything
there is to see here is I'm going to copy
and paste them over.
But there is one more thing that's new that
we need to create in this particular file.
Okay, as you can see, we've got a couple different
textiles here.
So the last thing we need to do is create
a typography object.
So basically, what that's going to mean is
that we're going to assign some of the text
styles that we've created below, which are
used in common things like the body text of
a particular feature of the application, buttons,
titles, that kind of thing.
If that doesn't make sense.
Let's just write the code.
Make sure you select compose dot material,
not kotlin dot txt.
Okay, we're just gonna do To more.
All right, and the only other thing we need
to do is set up our graph Sudoku theme.
Right click on the UI package, and we've got,
you guessed it another kotlin file.
And it's going to be called graph Sudoku themed.
So one of the handy little features of jetpack
compose is that it is incredibly easy to create
a theme for light and dark modes.
As someone who uses generally speaking, dark
mode almost always actually really appreciate
this particular feature of compose.
The first step in that process is to create
two different color palettes.
Let's start with the light color palette.
So some of these properties should probably
be familiar to most Android developers like
having a color primary.
That's how we used to do it also in the old
XML system with colors, or at least that was
a common naming convention.
Now, one thing I want to point out here is
that there's a degree to which some of these
more obscure ones like primary variant surface
on primary and so forth, I'm really just using
those because it's convenient, they don't
necessarily have to mean anything in particular.
But the important thing to understand here
is that if there's any different color between
a light theme and a dark theme, we do want
to define it somewhere in here, and then use
it appropriate in the composable, which we'll
be learning to do later on.
Okay, that was actually supposed to be uppercase
there by convention.
And also notice that I've copy pasted over
the dark color palette, because again, there's
nothing new going on there.
The next step, however, is very important,
we're going to create our theme, and it's
actually going to be really, really easy.
Here's a little shortcut I learned from a
friend, if you want to create a composable
function really quickly start typing comp,
and then hit enter, just saves you a little
bit of time.
Now this theme is going to have two parameters
here.
So before we write the body of this function,
I just wanted to discuss these two parameters.
So as you can see, we're actually making a
function call is system in dark theme, what's
going to happen is this system call will return
a Boolean, which will tell us whether the
user has specified if the app is supposed
to be in dark mode or light mode.
And then the content represents everything
that will be wrapped inside of this theme.
What's important to understand here is that
everything that we put inside of this composable,
ie the content will have access to all these
different colors, styles and typography information
from within the theme itself.
The actual utility of this will make a lot
more sense when we actually write the composable.
Just to finish things off, we're going to
create a material theme composable.
And we won't need the lambda expression.
So there you have it, it only took a few minutes
to create like the color resources and styles
and typography information necessary to render
both a dark color palette and a light color
palette for different modes.
What I'm going to do is show you a quick demo
of what this actually looks like in an application.
Here I'm going to be starting the application
in the light theme.
Then I'm going to navigate to the operating
system settings and set it to a preferred
dark mode.
And upon returning we see immediately that
the application now is using the dark theme.
We're now ready to start building our user
interface.
The UI components package contains reusable
elements of the user interface.
Since this is a very small app, the only two
such elements are a toolbar, and a loading
screen.
One of the great features of compose is that
we can make our components reusable in different
ways.
Firstly, if a component needs to be positioned
according to where it fits in different parent
composable, or parent screens, we can pass
in a modifier instead of creating a modifier
within the child composable.
This is worth experimenting with in case you
haven't already.
Secondly, it is possible to pass in composable
as arguments, which also allows reuse and
extension of functionality.
In this app, we want different toolbar icons
for the two different UI screens.
And we can achieve this by passing in the
icon compostables.
From those parent UI screens, you'll see later
on how we can specify and handle different
icons and different click events.
Using the same toolbar will also create this
reusable loading screen and later, I will
show you how to animate it, right click on
the UI package and go to new package.
And this one's going to be called components.
Just a brief explanation here, I've adopted
this particular convention from the composed
samples repository.
So what will go into this particular folder
are composable, which will end up being reusable
across a variety of different UI elements
and different screens.
In this case, we're going to be creating a
reusable toolbar, and also a reusable loading
screen, right click on the components folder,
and go to New kotlin file, and this one's
going to be called app toolbar.
Let's create our functions stub, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to type co MP and
then the autocomplete will create a composable
function.
This one's going to be called app toolbar.
First, let's write the parameter list and
I'll explain it a little bit.
Make sure you select the compose.ui modifier.
Let's start by talking a little bit about
modifiers.
So modifiers are basically how you can create
most of these styles size and position kind
of data for a particular composable.
Now there's kind of two different main ways
to do this.
We could of course, create this modifier and
use it within this widget.
But that would be for a situation when the
widget itself is going to be deciding that
kind of information.
Since we're using a reusable component here,
an app toolbar, which we plan to use in multiple
different places.
In this particular situation, we're going
to pass the modifier into this function, which
is a way of basically saying that the parent
composable will actually decide where to position
and how to size this particular UI element.
The title is pretty self explanatory, but
what is a little more complicated is the icon.
And again, that will be dictated by something
in the parent composable.
That's how I actually make this thing reusable
and allow it to handle different icons or
different actions when it's clicked.
After we finish off this particular composable,
I'll show you a quick preview of the actual
icon that we'll be using.
So hopefully that will make a little bit more
sense.
The first thing we want to do is override
the top app bar composable.
Let's just pause a moment and talk about different
colors.
So one way to solve this problem would be
to hard code some kind of color in here.
But in the previous section of this tutorial,
we went through the trouble of setting up
both a light and dark theme.
So what we're doing here is we're actually
going to be using a color which is based on
the theme.
Remember in the graph Sudoku theme composable,
there was a call to a function which was his
system and dark theme or something like that.
And that's actually going to dictate which
color palette we select.
So by using material theme colors dot primary,
it will automatically inherit the appropriate
color based on whether we're in light and
dark mode.
And that would be one reason to avoid hard
coding something in here.
In this case, we have a color which will be
the same regardless of whether it's light
or dark mode.
So we're just going to add in a text composable
which is effectively eight Extra view.
But if you wanted to add something like a
logo for the application in front or after
the title text, and what you could do is you
could add in a row here and then just add
in both the icon and then the text composable.
And then you'd be ready to go.
Go ahead and import that.
This is probably pretty self explanatory.
But when we want to inherit style data for
particular fonts and stuff like that, then
this is how we can do it.
Again, this is something super handy.
And you only see this in kotlin, certainly
not Java.
So what we're doing here is we're explicitly
asking is the application currently in light
mode, and then we're picking a text color
based on that.
This is really just an alternative way of
handing this conditional UI logic without
having to assign something to a theme specifically.
Next, we'll deal with alignment.
And that's it for the texts composable in
our toolbar.
So action bar is probably something that will
be more familiar to the older Android developers.
But basically think of this is like the icons
within the toolbar.
Generally, they're used for very important
actions in the user interface, like navigating
to a new feature, indicating that you're done
doing something.
And note importantly, that this particular
lambda function is of type row scope.
So basically, what that means is, if you have
several action buttons, you can place them
within these two brackets here, and they will
automatically be lined up like a row.
Now all we need to do is just type icon and
then add in the parentheses here.
And this is because we're actually going to
be passing this icon in from the parent composable.
As I said, moments ago, I just wanted to give
you a sneak preview of the icon itself.
We're not going to be writing it yet, but
we will do so later on.
The important thing to understand here is
that we're deciding about how to handle on
click and what this thing actually looks like
in the parent composable, we're not actually
doing it within the toolbar.
And by pulling that responsibility out of
the toolbar, that's how we get the reusability
that we want.
Right click on the components package, go
to New kotlin file, and this one's going to
be called loading screen.
Let's create our loading screen composable.
The first thing we'll need is
a surface.
So you might be wondering, why are we using
a surface here in particular, in this case,
I really just want like a space surface of
the UI, which has a particular color and specific
dimensions.
Here I've set Phil max height to a fraction
of point eight F, which is basically saying
I want it to take up most of the width, or
sorry, most of the height of the user interface.
But I might want some space for something
like a an ad banner or something of that nature.
Anyways, I basically want an icon or an image
which is stacked on top of a progress bar
which will be stacked on top of some kind
of like text.
So for that kind of situation, obviously we're
going to want to use a column.
Obviously, we'll be centering things.
Go ahead and import that.
Now I'm noticing it's not improperly importing
our I think there's something within the Compose
libraries, which basically mimics our so let
me just fix those imports before we proceed.
As you can see here, I've just copy and pasted
it in the our import.
And now we're good to go.
That's our logo.
Here's your progress bar.
Okay, so you might be wondering about this
painter thing.
So basically, in the alpha version of compose,
we had to specify whether it was a vector
asset or a bitmap asset and stuff like that.
So we can just use this generic painter resource
thing and point it to basically anything in
our drawable.
And it will actually figure out whether it's
a bitmap or a vector asset.
Also, I wanted to point out the copy function
here.
Suppose you have a color and you want to slightly
change the alpha value or you have one of
these textile objects and you want to make
some kind of change to it.
The copy function is super handy for doing
that.
In this part of the tutorial, we will create
the event sealed class view model and presenter
for the act of game feature.
Before we do that, let us look at a few design
decisions involved in this architecture.
The purpose of our presentation logic class,
which I call logic, for short, is exactly
as the name implies, it handles the work of
coordinating the container view model and
backend repositories.
If notified of a non stop event, it will also
cancel all co routines, it does not possess
any Android platform code, which makes it
loosely coupled and very easy to test.
I might also consider reusing it for a desktop
version of this app.
But we'll see.
The purpose of the view model is also to do
exactly what the name implies, it is a virtual
representation of the user interface, which
the view observes.
In simpler terms, it is a model of the view,
it exposes function types, which is a very
simple and easy standing for the observer
pattern.
In situations where we don't require multiple
observers.
Each time our logic class updates the view
model, the view model will automatically publish
the new data to the view.
Another design decision with this view model
is that it does not extend jetpack view model.
There are several reasons for this decision,
some of them simple, and some of them quite
technical.
The simple reason is that using jetpack view
model creates tight coupling with the Android
platform.
And it has its own set of boilerplate code
and dependencies, which I'm not a huge fan
of.
In short, it doesn't solve more problems than
it creates in this particular application.
And I wanted to practice creating view models
which might be usable for kotlin desktop or
kotlin.
j s.
The technical reason why is that in this application,
we simply don't need to persist the data across
activity instances or process death in order
to have a good user experience.
Instead, we just make a fairly cheap call
to the Android file system and reload the
data from there if such events occur.
Now, before you apply that reasoning in every
situation, understand that reloading data
from a file system works fine in this application,
but should not be considered a suitable replacement
for unsaved instance state in every application
you write.
If you like the models in save state handle,
go right ahead and use it.
We also employ the strategy pattern to clean
up the interface which our logic class exposes
to the container in the view.
Each subclass of the sealed class represents
an action that can occur in the view or container.
Rather than having a function for every UI
event.
We have one function that accepts a single
object that can represent multiple different
paths of execution.
That's the strategy pattern.
Right click On the UI package, and go to new
package called active game, right click on
this new package, go to New kotlin file or
class, and we're going to create an interface,
and it's going to be called active game container.
This word container is a technical term.
The way I'm using it here is to kind of signify
something which contains a large portion of
an application or an entire application.
In my opinion, a container doesn't usually
deal much with the business kind of logic
of the application.
It basically just wires things together and
builds things and kind of serves as an entry
point.
In the next part of this tutorial, I'll explain
what we'll actually be using as a container.
But by using an interface here, I'm basically
stating quite explicitly that I might change
my mind about what we use as a container.
Anyways, it only contains two abstract functions.
Right click on the active game package again,
and we're going to create a sealed class this
time.
And it's going to be called active game event.
So as I explained in the above comment, the
active game event sealed class represents
every kind of user interaction of a given
feature, in this case, the active game feature.
This is a very common pattern that I use and
we'll see how it works with our base logic
abstract class which we created in the common
package.
Okay, we are now going to create our view
model.
Firstly, let's create a small little class
here which will be like a virtual representation
of a single tile in a Sudoku puzzle.
So obviously, x&y represent the x&y coordinates
of the particular Sudoku tile value will represent
what we talked about in graph data structures
as the color again, it's literally just a
number, I don't know why we need to call it
a color.
Now it has focused indicates that the user
has clicked on a particular tile, after which
they can click on one of the input buttons
to change that particular number.
And finally, a read only tile you can think
of as a tile, which is like a given clue in
the puzzle.
So therefore, the user is not allowed to actually
change any read only tiles.
So before we start reading this view model,
I just wanted to mention a couple of things
here.
As discussed in the introduction for this
particular section, I didn't actually want
to use any of the jetpack libraries to achieve
a publisher subscriber relationship between
the view model and the view.
Now, it turns out that that publisher, subscriber
relationship or pattern is actually quite
easy to implement.
But in this case, I actually found it simpler
to just use kotlin function types to achieve
what I would call a poor person's publisher,
subscriber pattern or observer pattern.
So this really means something simple in practice,
although it might look kind of complicated
for those who aren't really familiar with
working with function types.
Our view model will possess these nullable
function type references.
As we'll see in a moment, what we can do is
each time we update the view model from the
presentation logic class, we can then update
the view by extension by invoking these function
types from within the view model.
Now, the reason why we're using notables here
is from within the view model.
I can never be 100% certain if there is actually
anything listening.
But with that being said, I feel like if I
played around with this particular class for
a couple of hours, I could probably streamline
a little bit and maybe make some of these
internal variables private or something like
that.
So really what I'm saying here is Feel free
to take this general idea of having a view
model, which isn't tightly coupled to Android
jetpack, but also feel free to experiment
with it and see if you can optimize it.
So with that out of the way, let's create
some function types.
So all of these function types will be prefixed
with sub to ensure good legibility.
Active game screen state is actually something
we will create in the next part of this tutorial.
So just go ahead and leave it glowing red
here.
Okay, let me just briefly explain these different
function types.
So the board state is basically a virtual
representation of the Sudoku board.
Obviously, the content state basically just
means three different states.
So either we're loading the data, the user
has a currently active game that they're solving,
or the user has completed a particular game,
we will use this to animate between different
states in the user interface.
Now, timer state has to do with the count
up timer, which basically records how long
it takes for the user to complete a given
Sudoku game.
So just to hopefully clear up any confusion
here, timer state will be the actual long
value in milliseconds representing the time
and then sub timer state is the way that we
actually update the user interface after we
update the new timer state.
Let's finish off the rest of these variables.
These are quite obviously default values.
Next, we'll write a function to initialize
this view model.
Okay, so let's just pause for a moment.
What we're doing here is we're taking the
state of the data as it existed in storage,
we're giving it to the view model, and then
what we're doing is we're building the view
models own virtual representation of that
state.
Now, the view models internal representations
will have things like has focus, which are
concerned specifically of the user interface
and not necessarily something that I would
include in the original domain model.
Also, in case you're wondering, the key value
is basically created from hashing the x value
and the y value.
This is something that we covered very early
on in this tutorial, in case you've jumped
ahead.
Again, active gain screen state is something
that we will create in the Compose part of
the tutorial.
Here, we're binding that data to the view
model.
And then we will invoke our function types
to update the view assuming it's listening.
And that's it for our init function.
Now, we just have a few more functions, which
will be called by our presenter to do various
things with the state of the view model.
So here, we're just updating an individual
tile.
So what we're doing here is when the user
hits a particular tile, that's going to send
a message into the presenter, which will have
a particular x and y coordinate, and then
the presenter will call this particular function.
And so what it will do is it will look for
the tile which the user clicked on based on
that X and Y value, and set that one to has
focus equals true.
And then for every other tile, we want to
set it to false.
Otherwise, we could have a situation where
the user has selected multiple different tiles,
which is not something our application is
supposed to be allowed to Do and this would
be the situation where our back end has determined
that the current puzzle is complete.
Right click on the active game package.
And let's create a new kotlin class, which
is going to be called active game logic.
Okay, so before we proceed, this is definitely
one of those situations where I strongly suggest
having the complete source code open on the
side while you follow along here.
Obviously, I'm going to do my best not to
make any mistakes, but it's possible that
I will make a mistake.
Active game logic represents the presentation
logic of this particular feature of the application.
As we'll see, it coordinates between the container
the view model, and then by extension, the
view, as well as the back end of the application.
Let's start with the constructor.
Okay, so just a bit of review before we move
on, for the time being the container will
actually be an activity.
But there's a possibility in the future, I
might move to using fragments as containers
instead, at this point, I don't really want
to, but we'll just see if that makes sense
in the future.
But this is the entire reason why I have included
an interface here so that I can change what's
behind the interface very easily.
The view model is pretty clear, we just wrote
it.
Game repo is where we store the game data.
So that includes the game settings as well
as the current progress of the users game
stats.
repple is where we store the records for the
shortest times to completion of each different
difficulty and size of puzzle.
And if you're wondering what the dispatcher
is go back and watch the common package when
we created that we created this dispatcher
provider and I basically explained what the
purpose of it is there.
Base logic is also something that we created
in the common package.
And we'll see the function that we inherit
from that class in a moment.
Okay, let's start for a moment about co routines.
So one way to think about scopes, whether
we're talking about co routine scope, or dagger
or whatever, is to really just consider that
it's about a life cycle.
Now, you're probably wondering, why are we
not making something like a view model or
a fragment or an activity, our life cycle
class?
Well, in case you haven't noticed by now,
I don't like any kind of tight coupling to
the Android platform, if I can avoid it.
There's a number of other reasons.
But one of the main ones is that because this
class contains all of the presentation logic,
in a sense, it's the head decision maker for
this feature of the application, then, in
my opinion, it makes sense to make it responsible
for cancellation of any co routines, which
happened to be currently running as far as
this on event function, which we inherit from
base logic.
Well, basically, this is an implementation
of the strategy pattern.
I won't give you a long and technical explanation
here.
It's actually a very simple pattern.
But basically, it provides sort of like a
singular entry point into this particular
class.
So instead of having like a single function,
for every event, we have one function, which
takes in an argument, our active game event,
which is capable of representing all the different
events, and I just find that really cleans
up the interfaces between different classes,
interfaces is used in the general sense in
that statement.
Okay, first, let's implement our co routine
context.
Remember, jobtracker exists in base logic,
but we also need to initialize it Okay, now
before we proceed, there's something really
important we need to implement which is a
ko routine timer.
As I mentioned before, the active game Screen
does have a count up timer.
Now some of you are probably going to be wondering,
why didn't I use the Java timer class or the
androids count up timer or whatever it's called.
Basically, I did try using those things.
And they presented different application breaking
problems.
And it turned out to be easiest just to create
this kind of CO routine timer.
Okay, so this requires a little bit of explanation,
obviously.
So we'll notice two different keywords here,
which might be unfamiliar to some of you,
we have the inline and cross inline keywords.
So whenever you see the inline keyword, the
easiest way to understand that is to understand
that it just means copy, paste.
And if you want to know what that means in
code, then I suggest you decompile some of
your kotlin code, which uses the inline modifier,
and you'll see how the inline function is
actually copy and pasted into the call site.
Now we have something else going on here,
which is a cross inline function type.
So before I explain what the cross inline
action is, let's talk about what this function
actually does.
So here we have a pretty standard spin lock,
while true.
So it's a loop that's going to just endlessly
execute, it's going to invoke that function
type, and then it's going to delay for 1000
milliseconds.
Now, there's a couple different things going
on here.
Number one, you have to understand that we
will be delaying this ko routine, but it's
not actually going to block the thread that
it's on, which is of course a big win.
Now the other thing that's going on here is
action is going to be a lambda expression
that we will pass into this particular function.
Really the only thing crossing line does is
it basically makes it so that in the lambda
function, which we will pass into this function
here, we're not allowed to write a return
statement in that function.
So in the most general sense here, what we're
doing is we're taking a preventative step,
to avoid a situation where we might accidentally
return from within the lamda that we pass
in here causing unexpected behavior.
Now, you're probably wondering, since we have
this endless loop going on, how do we actually
stop this particular core routine?
Well, what we're going to do is we're going
to create a job.
Let's just do that now.
And what we'll do soon is we will actually
assign this job variable to our start co routine
timer, and that will allow us to cancel it.
Let's just write another quick extension function
to do with this timer business and then I'll
explain what it does.
In experimenting with the user interface,
how to make the timer the least janky or most
accurate that it could be it turned out that
subtracting one from the value each time we
write it to the back end created a more consistent
timer.
But one particular edge case is if the value
equals zero, then obviously we don't want
to subtract one from it.
Otherwise the timer will say negative one
at first and that just doesn't look very good.
Okay, so with all that done, we can get to
implementing the rest of the presentation
logic Okay, so when the user hits an input
button, we can have two different situations
that could occur.
In one situation, the user has already selected
a tile, which would become the focus tile.
Or it might be that they just hit an input
button without actually focusing a tile, in
which case, we don't really want to do anything.
Okay, so if you're wondering about the details
of game repo, you can go back to the part
of the tutorial where we actually build it.
Basically, we're going to be creating a lambda
to represent the success case, and then another
lambda to represent like an error exception
case, to make that a little bit more legible.
I'll just add in a comment here.
Okay, so if you're again, wondering how we
actually cancel the timer, this is exactly
how we do it, we cancel the job object.
Now we'll write this other function in a moment.
Basically, if it's a new record, then we want
to render the user interface slightly differently
than if it wasn't a record.
But before we do that, let's finish off the
error case.
So in order to actually know if it's record,
we actually need to pass the value back into
the stats repo just to check on that.
So I'm going to be honest, the error handling
in this application is not the best, neither
is it really the worst show error Well, for
the time being just actually show a toast
message explaining that some error occur.
Okay, just a quick fix.
This is actually supposed to be elapsed time
not timer state.
Next, we have on new game clicked.
You'll notice a recurring theme here, which
is at any time we want to perform concurrent
operations.
So anytime we're working with the back end,
we're going to wrap that into a launch co
routine.
There's a lot of different ways to work with
CO routines.
This is just one of the most simple straightforward
ways to do it.
In my opinion.
Okay, so
what we're doing here is first we're asking
the view model has the user completed the
current game, if they haven't, we actually
want to store the progress the user has made
in their current game, when they hit on new
game clicked, because maybe they hit it by
accident, or they want to be able to go back
and finish the game or some reason like that.
That's right The update with time function.
Again, we have success and error cases.
Hopefully, that's pretty clear at this point.
Next, we'll implement that function.
Next, we'll write the cancel stuff function.
So basically, the cancel stuff function essentially
cancels every ko routine.
Next, we'll write on start.
I forgot to
mention earlier, the reason why we had an
underscore in one of the functions for is
complete.
It's just kind of a convention for a lambda
argument or parameter, which doesn't actually
end up getting used.
In this case, we're going to use it.
Okay, so obviously, this is where we start
the coroutine timer, and we only want to do
that when on start is called.
Now, again, I feel like I could have handled
this a little bit better, it kind of goes
against my rules to consider standard flow
the application as an exception.
But basically, what we're going to do here
is in the event that we ask the storage for
a current game, and it doesn't actually retrieve
anything, generally speaking, this situation
is going to occur when the user has run the
application for the first time, and hence,
there wouldn't actually be any data stored.
So in that particular case, we would want
to do this.
Now, we could also end up here because of
some kind of legitimate exception, but in
that particular case, I still think navigating
to the new game feature is still actually
a good way to handle that good but maybe not
the best.
Next we have on stop.
Okay, so onstop is actually tied to the lifecycle
of the Android activity or fragment that it's
bound to.
So when this function is called, that basically
means that we want to save the user's current
progress and then kind of shut everything
down.
Finally, we have on tile focus.
So this would be when a user actually selects
a particular Sudoku tile.
Now this function is incredibly complicated,
so brace yourself.
Okay, I lied.
That's actually everything we need to do.
In this part of the tutorial, we will create
the user interface for the active game feature.
Before proceeding I strongly suggest you watch
my video entitled How to Understand jetpack
compose a beginner's guide to composable and
read composition.
We will be writing many composable and setting
up re composition as well.
But that video is made for people who are
just getting started with compose.
It explains what a composable is, what read
composition is and how to avoid doing read
composition the wrong way.
And believe me, it is fairly easy to screw
up read composition if you aren't aware of
how it works.
I will link to this video in the pinned comment
below.
This video is full of a ton of information,
so please take a look at the timestamps in
the description box below.
Topics include basic widgets, such as text,
text, button, image, icon, spacer, and divider
layouts, such as box column row box with constraints
and my favorite constraint layout.
Simple transition animations to animate between
a loading screen, active game and a complete
game.
I also show you how to communicate with our
presentation logic and our view model using
function types and lambda expressions.
Before we write the composed code, though,
I show you how to set up an activity as a
container for composable.
The process for doing this is almost identical
for fragments if you prefer them, I also show
you how to write a very simple dependency
injection extension function, which hides
the backend details from the front end.
Right click on the active game package and
go to new activity and choose an empty activity.
And make sure you uncheck generate a layout
file.
And this activity will be called active game
activity.
It will be the launcher activity.
Now in case you're wondering why we're using
this wizard instead of just creating a class
file.
The reason is simply that by using the wizard
it will add an entry into the manifest so
we don't have to do that.
Just to briefly recap the purpose of this
activity here is as a feature specific container.
Let's start by creating a reference to our
active game logic class.
Next, let's implement the active game container
interface.
Click on the red and hit alt enter.
For show error, we will use the extension
function that we created way earlier on in
this tutorial.
Go ahead and import.
Also in case you're wondering, this is single
expression syntax here it basically just replaces
the brackets and return statement with just
an equal sign.
Next one implement on new game click.
Now obviously we haven't created new game
activity yet so that will show up as red until
we do.
We also need to override two more lifecycle
methods.
Here will tell the logic class that everything
is ready to go
And then we'll also override on stop.
And that will obviously signal the logic class
that it's time to cancel things and tear stuff
down.
Finally, we just need to add a few lines to
on create.
First of all, create the view model.
Now, this is a really important part, what
we're going to do next is we're basically
going to anchor our composable that we'll
be creating in the next part of this tutorial,
to the activity here.
This is also something you can call inside
of a fragment.
Go ahead and import that.
Naturally, we're gonna wrap everything in
our compose theme.
Now, this is a very critically important thing
to understand and a very important pattern.
So when we create active game screen, we're
going to pass in a function type, which will
serve as our event handler, which is basically
my way of saying that is the way in which
we will forward the events, the onClick events
and stuff like that, that occur in the composable
to our presentation logic class.
So make sure you pay attention to what I'm
saying here, because this is a really important
part, even if you don't use presenters wood,
or whatever.
Function types are an excellent way to handle
on click events, especially if you combine
them with the strategy pattern, which we discussed
in the previous section.
Okay, now, if you've never seen a function
reference, I believe it's called basically
what we're doing here is we are pointing to
the on event function of the logic class.
This really is a function reference.
So hopefully, you can understand what I'm
talking about here.
We'll also pass in the view model.
Now lastly, we actually need to build our
logic class.
So what we'll do is we will write that code
in an extension function, but what we can
do first is just read it here.
And that's everything we need to do in our
activity.
Right click on active game, go to new package,
and this package will be called build logic.
Right click on that package and go to New
kotlin file or classes is going to be a file.
And it's going to be called build active game
logic.
If you've been watching my channel, or live
streams for some time, you'll know that I
talk a lot about dependency injection service
locators.
And one of the things I say all the time is
that in a small application, you really don't
need to use di container, like hilt, dagger,
whatever, you can use it.
But what I always advise for beginners is
to write the code that these things generate
for you, yourself first, so that you understand
what these frameworks are doing for you.
So that's exactly what we're going to do.
We're going to write the kind of thing that
these frameworks generate for you.
And in a small application, it's actually
very simple code to write.
And, of course, it's going to return active
game logic.
Okay, let's pause for just one moment here.
So in case you're wondering how we get the
path to the storage directory that we can
use for this application, you can call context
dot files dir dot path.
Finally, our dispatcher.
And that's all we need to do.
Right click on the active game feature, and
create new kotlin file called active game
screen.
First, let's create an enum.
This enum represents different states, which
this feature of the user interface can possess.
The actual state is held in the view model,
but we will see how we can update our composable
UI by binding to the view models function
types we created in the previous part of this
tutorial.
Active game screen represents the root composable.
In this hierarchy of composable, it has the
responsibility of setting up the core elements
of the UI, and also animating between them.
event handler function type reference is how
we call back to the presentation logic.
When the user interacts with the application,
it must be passed down to any composable,
which has such interactions, we also pass
in the view model, which is how we actually
give the data to our UI.
In very simple language, whenever we have
some kind of data or state, which may change
at runtime, we want to wrap that data in a
remember delegate.
This tells the Compose library under the hood,
to watch for changes and to redraw the UI
if a change occurs.
Now mutable transition state is used specifically
for animations here, so don't use this everywhere.
We will see a more general purpose example
of a remembered state later on.
Remember, delegate prepares compose for updates,
but we also need a way to actually update
the value.
We do this by binding a lambda expression
to one of the function types which our view
model possesses.
When one of those functions is invoked in
the view model, the program automatically
jumps to and executes this code within our
composable.
This is what actually triggers the re composition.
We have a remembered transition state and
a way to update that state from the view model.
Now we need to set up the transition animations
themselves.
This is where you can get as creative as you
like.
In this app.
Each content state has its own composable
associated with it.
We animate between them simply by changing
the alpha value or transparency.
Now it was truly up as red a moment ago, the
way I fixed that was to manually import the
Compose runtime.
So the transition spec tells compose details
about what the animation should look like.
Essentially, this means we don't have to write
our own mathematical instructions, which is
great for someone like me who sucks at arithmetic.
One option for compose is to use the scaffold
composable as a skeleton for your UI.
I personally prefer to do this myself, since
it's not really that difficult, and it doesn't
hide anything from me.
First, we have our app toolbar.
Let's go ahead and create that new game icon.
These icons come from the Compose material
library, I highly recommend you use it.
This is how we actually trigger an on click
event.
As explained in a previous part of the tutorial,
by creating our toolbar icon here and passing
it into the app toolbar composable, we make
the app toolbar reusable.
Below the toolbar we have the main content
of this screen, which can have three different
states.
Each time a re composition occurs, this one
statement will be executed again.
The act of alpha value will change when the
transition animation occurs, thus fading out
the previous content state and fading in the
new one.
Obviously, we will create these in a moment.
And that's it for our route composable the
most complex part of our UI comes from an
active Sudoku game.
A nine by nine puzzle has 81 different texts
composable, which is a large number of widgets.
The way I went about writing this composable
was to think of each part of the Sudoku game
as a particular layer or element.
Be sure to avoid writing God composable by
making usage of helper functions, which break
down the UI into the smallest reasonable parts.
box with constraints is kind of like a composable
wrapper, which gives us information about
the height, width and other measurements,
we can use that information within its lambda
expression.
We need to know the screen width in order
to determine how wide and tall the Sudoku
board should be.
Here we asked for the max width of this constraint
layout.
Here we ask for the max width of this layout
composable.
But we need that value to be in density independent
pixels, and it needs to be relative to the
density of the current screen as well.
That's where the two dp extension function
comes in.
And it uses the local density to determine
that value.
The margin of the board also needs to change
based on the screen density.
I arrived at these values simply by testing
the app on various densities using the emulator.
Next, we will write a constraint layout, which
is a totally awesome way to manage dynamic
layouts.
Now in order to constrain composable to each
other, we need a way for them to reference
each other.
This is equivalent to setting IDs for XML
views.
First, we create these references and you
will see how to bind them later on.
Let's create a layout container for the puzzle
board.
Okay, so this is really important see how
we're passing in that reference in the constrain
as parameter there.
This is how we actually associate a particular
composable with a particular reference.
This box composable will be associated with
the name board.
Next we'll create the Sudoku board itself.
Again, the boundary is like the size of the
puzzle.
So it's either a four by four puzzle or a
nine by nine puzzle.
So boundary would either be four or nine.
This is supposed to say size.
So the offset here is used to evenly distribute
the screen real estate for each Sudoku, tile
and grid line.
Here's a way to make a mutable state which
is not associated with some kind of transition
animation.
So this is the more general purpose approach.
So the first argument here view model dot
board state can be thought of as the initial
value, never equal policy ensures that even
minor changes in the state like has focus
actually triggers a re composition.
Again, this is how we actually update the
value once the view model is updated.
As you can see, here, again, I'm making usage
of lots of helper functions to break things
down.
Here we render the text fields which represent
tiles in the puzzle, they can either be read
only or mutable, thus, meaning that we need
to render them slightly differently.
So here, we're saying if the user sets a particular
tile to a value of zero, we actually just
want to render it as an empty tile.
The main idea here is that we're using the
x and y values of each individual tile along
with the offset in order to evenly position
each tile
So when the user selects a tile, it's going
to become focused and we want to render that
tile obviously a little bit different than
an unfocused tile.
Now we'll render the read only squares.
Next we'll create the board grid.
So Sq RT is an extension, which is actually
defined in the computation logic.
In retrospect, I probably should have defined
that in the common package, but it's pretty
obvious what it does.
So this function here, we'll draw the grid
lines that separate the Sudoku puzzles.
To make it more obvious to the user which
sub grids are which we draw different borders
to separate the four by four or nine by nine
sub grids.
This is why we're using modulo here.
So this will draw both the vertical and the
horizontal lines.
Okay, so we're jumping back into the game
content composable to finish it off.
below our Sudoku board, we have some different
icons to indicate the difficulty of the puzzle.
Next we need a layout container for the count
up timer that's great, the timer texts composable.
Now
the default value, it's just empty.
Okay, we're back in the game content composable.
The last thing we need to do is just add a
layout container for the input buttons.
Now we're about to hard code some values in
here and that is kind of bad practice.
But the reason is that the Compose team deprecated
flow row, which I'm still upset about, and
it worked perfectly for this situation, and
I've been too lazy to implement flow myself.
Hey, at least I'm being honest.
In case you're wondering, 0.4 and five dot
dot nine will emit a range inclusive of those
values.
Let's create that composable a spacer is pretty
self explanatory, it just takes up some space
in the layout.
Next we have the buttons themselves.
This text button wrapper allows us to style
a nice looking button instead of just adding
on click on a text composable.
Alright, that's it for gain content.
Now we need to do the game complete content
screen, which is obviously when a user finishes
a game.
So this is basically just two images stacked
on top of each other, but we're only going
to render one of them if it is actually a
new record that the user made.
So since we don't actually create the emoji
events icon, we can change the color of it
using this color filter thing.
Pretty handy.
Next, we have to text composable.
And that's it.
Congratulations.
In this part of the tutorial, we will examine
the topic of graph data structures, mostly
with respect to solving Sudoku.
Unlike the rest of this tutorial, which is
presented in a code along format, This lesson
will be different.
Instead of rewriting all the code, we will
look at the basics of a graph data structure.
How I modeled a Sudoku puzzle as a graph data
structure, how I created, tested and improved
my algorithms to the point where they could
generate 100 puzzles in roughly 400 milliseconds.
before I proceed, I suggest you read my article
on Free Code Camp, which explains the fundamentals
of software engineering in a clear and accessible
way.
That article explains these topics assuming
only that you have some basic coding skills.
Let's start by asking a question, what are
graph data structures?
The simplest verbal explanation I can think
of is that they are a family of data structures,
which are useful for modeling a bunch of things
which are connected in some way.
To connect that definition with something
visual, you can imagine that the bunch of
things are a series of nodes or points, and
the connections between them are a series
of edges, which you can think of as lines
connecting the points.
So whenever I say the phrase graph data structure,
a better term for most people to understand
this topic is a network data structure.
In fact, that is exactly how they are used
in apps like Facebook to represent users and
friends.
Google Maps to represent city addresses in
the roads connecting them or Sudoku puzzles
to represent tiles which have relationships
to each other.
According to the game's rules.
Pictures and words are fine, but the code
is more important.
How do we tell a computer system to virtually
represent a Sudoku puzzle?
This process is more concrete than you might
think, though, it helps to be an expert in
the programming language you're using.
In principle, the process is to take all of
the information you know about the problem
you're solving, ie the problem domain, and
start writing code which describes it.
First, we represent a single tile in a Sudoku
puzzle with the class Sudoku node.
It has a value x and y coordinates and a Boolean
to establish whether it can be edited or not
by the user.
Read Only true would indicate a node which
is a given clue at the start of a new Sudoku
game.
Now this term color really just means a value
from zero to the boundary of the puzzle.
So a nine by nine puzzle would have the colors
zero to nine.
To be honest, I don't like using the term
color as it confused my hyper literal brain.
But please understand that it really is just
a number value.
And the term color is actually irrelevant
in this problem domain.
Where the word came from is that this kind
of data structure was used to solve a problem
that involved coloring different countries
on a map using a fixed set of colors.
We could have just as easily associated these
numbers with different kinds of sandwiches,
but to the computer, it is the same thing.
In any case, if you hear me say color, just
remember it's a value, it's a number, not
literally a color.
Now the data structure itself must include
every element, as well as the connections
or relationships between every element.
There is no single way to do this, but I arrived
at using a linked hash map datatype from the
kotlin standard library.
This data type preserves the ordering of its
elements, and allows me to find a specific
element based on a hash code.
The hash code itself comes from this simple
hashing function which generates a unique
key based on the x and y values of a node.
The linked lists themselves represent both
the root node at a given x&y location as well
as any other node which happens to be in the
same row column or sub grid of that root node.
The root node will always be the first node
in the list known as the head element.
But other than that, we don't care about the
ordering of the rest of the So after I figured
out how to model a Sudoku game in this way,
the next step was to start writing the algorithms
to manipulate my chosen data structure.
The first algorithm I wrote was called build
nodes.
Its job was to build the skeleton of our data
structure.
By adding an element for every tile in the
puzzle.
A square size in Sudoku will have n squared
tiles or elements.
So the first thing I did was write a unit
test to check for that condition.
Here we see the first example of the process
I used to write these algorithms.
I tried to solve the problem one step at a
time and to verify the correctness of each
step as I went.
Next, I knew that I needed to create the edges
or relationships between different tiles based
on the rules of the game, nodes would share
a column may not have the same value or color
nodes would share a row may not have the same
value, nodes would share the same sub grid
may not have the same value.
Now, we haven't actually added any values
yet, but we can still build the edges of the
graph using these rules.
After looking at a picture of a four by four,
nine by nine in 16.
By 16 Sudoku puzzle, I was able to determine
that every tile will have the same number
of edges as any other tile, and those numbers
happened to be 821 and 40, respectively.
At first, the test was failing.
But I figured out that a node can be for example,
in the same column and subgrid.
So I needed in my algorithm to be smarter
about avoiding those kinds of repeats.
The previous two algorithms were childsplay.
Whereas now we get into some more difficult
problems.
The seed colors algorithm caused me huge problems
and took many days to get working properly.
The purpose of this algorithm was to provide
some initial values, ie seed values to make
the next step in the algorithm easier.
At first, I tried to do this by distributing
the values diagonally, which is a relatively
safe way to avoid breaking the rules.
But this approach led me to an uneven distribution
of initial values.
I thought this was a problem and eventually
came up with a new algorithm that would make
horizontal and vertical passes of the entire
puzzle, allocating numbers in such a way that
was guaranteed not to break the rules and
provide an even distribution.
While I'm proud of this algorithm in a certain
way, on a certain level, it's also disgustingly
complicated and proved pretty difficult to
test, I settled on ensuring that it wasn't
creating an invalid puzzle, and it was allocating
a number of values roughly equal to A quarter
of the total number of tiles.
If I allocated too many tiles, it would cause
problems though, so I had to include some
hard coded edge cases, which I didn't really
like.
Perhaps most important algorithm in this series
of algorithms is the solver algorithm.
The solver algorithm takes in our seated graph
and attempts to solve the puzzle from there.
Now I had already written a few other solver
algorithms that didn't use graph data structures.
So I was curious to see if using a graph would
actually make this process easier.
In some ways it did, but it was still overall
quite difficult to write a high performance
solver for n sized Sudoku puzzles.
Every algorithm for generating a Sudoku puzzle
that I'm aware of makes usage of three things.
brute force random number assignment, checking
if these new assignments create an invalid
puzzle.
backtracking when an invalid puzzle is created,
or the algorithm is simply not able to allocate
any new values without actually breaking the
rules of the game.
The problem with brute force random number
assignment is that it scales very poorly as
the size of the puzzle grows, randomly generating
a four by four Sudoku puzzle is quite easy
that way.
But even a nine by nine puzzle can take a
long time if you just use random numbers and
backtracking.
There's no way the app would be any good if
the user had to sit and wait for five minutes
just for the app to generate a new puzzle.
As is often the case, the solution to this
problem came from figuring out the right question
to ask, How do I tell the computer to make
smart decisions about assigning values instead
of just purely random decisions.
In the end, I settled on giving the algorithm
a nice value, which is inspired by nice values
in CPU scheduling.
In principle, the algorithm will select an
empty tile and look at the number of possible
values we can assign to that tile with respect
to the rules of the game.
This is done by looking at the rest of the
elements in the linked list for that tile,
and seeing how many of them are already colored
that is given a value in a nine by nine puzzle
if eight other tiles in the list already have
a unique value than the tile we have currently
selected, can only have one possible correct
value.
If seven tiles are already colored, we have
a 50% chance of guessing the correct number
which is still pretty good odds.
So the nice value represents how picky the
algorithm is in deciding whether or not to
assign a value.
The nice value itself is adjusted constantly
with the basic idea being two things.
If the algorithm has looked at many elements
and could not find a sufficiently safe guess,
we increment the nice value, thus allowing
the algorithm to make riskier guesses.
If the algorithm assigns a value, it becomes
pickier again by decrementing the nice value.
The other important part of this algorithm
is the multistage backtracking.
This part was very difficult to figure out,
and it required trying a lot of different
approaches.
In order to work smoothly for four, nine and
16 boundary puzzles, I settled on using three
stages of backtracking.
In the first stage, when the algorithm gets
stuck, we remove half of the values we have
allocated to the puzzle.
In the second stage, we remove all values
we have allocated to the puzzle, but we keep
the same seated values.
In the final stage, we remove all values and
generate a new seed then reset the algorithm
to start from scratch.
After playing around with both the nice values
and the conditions for each stage of backtracking,
something magical happened, I made one small
change to the nice value adjustment.
And suddenly, as you can see from my benchmark
tests, the algorithm was generating 101 nine
by nine Sudoku puzzles in roughly 400 milliseconds
instead of over four minutes.
At first, I didn't trust what I was seeing.
But after removing the change I had just made,
we were right back two minutes instead of
milliseconds.
The key takeaway is that every time I made
a small change to the algorithm, I rerun the
benchmarks to see what changed.
Tests are absolutely critical when you are
writing new algorithms, as they tell you both
the correctness and efficiency of your code.
I was super excited to have a working Sudoku
solver that was crushing my benchmarks, but
there was still one more algorithmic dragon
to slay.
As you can guess a solved Sudoku puzzle is
not actually useful to a person looking to
solve a Sudoku game, which happens to be our
entire user base.
Having generated a complete and valid puzzle,
the next thing to do was to remove a certain
amount of values to make the game playable
again.
At first, I thought the difficulty of a Sudoku
puzzle was largely dependent on how many initial
clues are given to the user.
That idea is true at the extremes of a complete
puzzle or an empty puzzle, but not so true
in the middle.
What I mean is that you can definitely have
a Sudoku puzzle with 33 given clues that is
easy to solve without guessing and have a
puzzle with 38 given clues that is impossible
to solve without guessing.
So I suddenly realized that I was going to
need to invent some way of establishing the
difficulty of a Sudoku puzzle in a consistent
way.
Now, I knew that there must be some way to
do this mathematically.
But the truth is that mathematics is not a
natural way for me to solve problems.
I was great at calculus, but only for the
reason that I could visualize the graphs which
the equations described.
Instead of trying to model this problem in
mathematical terms, I visualize the things
that I actually do in order to solve various
difficulties of Sudoku puzzles.
I then figured out how to tell the computer
to employ these different strategies to attempt
to solve a puzzle without making any random
guesses.
This led to creating three kinds of strategies
which dictate the difficulty of a given puzzle.
In the basic solving strategy, a puzzle can
be solved simply by going through each square
and asking if there is only one possible value
that can be placed in that square based on
the rules of the game.
In the advanced strategy, we still use the
basic strategy, but we also look for a situation
where a node has two possible values, we then
look for another empty node, which has an
edge to the original node that also has the
same possible two values.
Finally, we test assigning both values to
both nodes.
Three things can occur when this happens if
both result in a valid Sudoku puzzle.
This doesn't actually help much because it's
possible to make valid assignments that still
result in an invalid puzzle later on.
If both result in an invalid puzzle, this
is obviously not a good situation.
Finally, if one configuration is valid, but
the other isn't, then logically, the valid
configuration is correct.
The final solving strategy basically means
that the puzzle cannot be solved in a purely
logical way, ie you must make guesses to solve
it, or it requires some kind of advanced strategy,
which I'm not aware of.
I'm not an expert in Sudoku, but I'm better
than the average player.
So either way, I would consider that to be
a hard puzzle.